bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france sur une réduction open contre une
vaccination
vous validez l'idée
oui bonjour non valide pas l'idée dit
logiquement sais pas
c'est pas ça nous au niveau des détenus
les rps donc les réductions de peine
supplémentaire ça s'applique seulement
ce pour la bonne conduite ou alors pour
un projet de réinsertion là on rentre
pas dans le cadre du de la loi donc nous
on est un peu étonné on considère que
s'ils doivent le faire c'est pour tout
le monde et pas que pour la maison
d'arrêt de sarreguemines or là il ya que
serge gumy qui est concerné c'est aussi
une prise de position assumée en faveur
de la vaccination quel regard est ce que
vous portez sur ce fait
le ministre a fait des annonces pendant
la pandémie en disant que les détenus
étaient pas des cobayes et qu'il n'était
pas obligé de se faire vacciner là
effectivement
c'est une incitation à la vaccination où
les détenus ou gagner une paire de jours
et pouvoir réduire leur peine alors le
centre pénitentiaire de baie-mahault en
guadeloupe a lui aussi déposé une offre
similaire le ministère de la justice
avait dans la foulée précisé qu'il
s'agissait d'une initiative très local
évoquant aussi une maladresse finalement
c'est pas si locale que ça visiblement
non ça a l'air de se propager du coup
comme vous l'avez dit outre-mer et puis
maintenant ça arrive en moselle
nous on n'est pas au bout maintenant à
voir les annonces du ministre on a vidé
les prisons lors de la première vague et
de la deuxième vague actuellement ça se
remplit la maison d'arrêt de
sarreguemines on est à 133% de
surpopulation carcérale donc voilà est
ce que c'est la solution qui a été
trouvée pour vider la prison ou pas et
nous on n'est pas fou et alors comment
réagissent les prisonniers qu'ils sont
concernés par cette initiative à
sarreguemines donc est-ce qu'ils sont
nombreux à vouloir saisir l'opportunité
quels sont les retours que vous avez
sincèrement bas c'est tout frais un seul
lot de hier soir donc on a beaucoup de
retours par rapport à la population
pénale je pense que certains vont
vouloir se faire vacciner parce qu'il y
en a il ne reste que 15 jours 3 semaines
1 a effectué donc je pense en faisant
cette injection ils sortiront d'une
façon générale quel est l'état de la
vaccination a aujourd'hui dans le milieu
carcéral
très faibles et faible il y a pas
beaucoup de candidats à la vaccination
l'administration pénitentiaire a enlevé
les moyens de les gestes barrière au
niveau des parloirs et actuellement il
ya une recrudescence des cas positifs
donc nous force ouvrir en redemande la
mise en place des mesures barrières au
niveau des parloirs et actuellement il
n'y a rien qui qui se fait pour quelle
raison est ce que les prisonniers ne
souhaite pas se faire vacciner
aucune idée est-ce que c'est comme une
partie de la population
la peur du vaccin on sait pas on n'a pas
agit pas de retour par rapport à cela
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne franck rassel
délégué régional fo pénitentiaire en
lorraine